many interesting things happen during
the 1980s one of those things was the
launching in 1983 of a large randomized
trial on folic acid and birth defects
this was the MRC vitamin study which
included women from 33 countries who
were planning to get pregnant amazingly
the risk of neural tube defects a type
of birth defect was reduced by 70% in
the group assigned to folic acid and
this was a big deal because newer tube
defects are serious birth defects that
happen when the central nervous system
does not close in the first 28 days of
pregnancy and this lack of closure can
lead to very serious disabilities or
death so the findings from the trial
were used to support major changes in
public health policy in the United
States the Centers for Disease Control
advises the all women should take point
for milligrams of folic acid every day
before getting pregnant and many
countries have implemented mandatory
fortification of wheat flour with folic
acid so women can get their daily dose
of folic acid from their food however
the emergency vitamin trial left some
questions unanswered first the study
only included women with history of
pregnancies affected by new activity
effects so would folic acid work for the
rest of the woman and second the study
gave women high doses of Pollock acid
with the same effect we seen with the
lower and possibly safer doses that were
usually included in more in multivitamin
supplements since no randomized trials
were available to answer these questions
investigators did what they always do
they analyzed data from observational
studies and one of those studies was the
Sloane epidemiology unit birth defects
study at Boston University this
observational study included pregnancies
from several North American cities in
the 1990s and this study estimated that
the risk of birth defect was 35 percent
lower among pregnancies exposed to folic
acid 35% lower that's a strong
association can we then conclude the
folic acid at the usual doses lowers the
risk of neural tube defects by 35
percent in normal woman or maybe more
educated women take more vitamins and
also do other things that reduce risk of
birth defects if that is the case then
we would expect to find a lower risk of
birth defects in folic acid users even
if folic acid had no effect on the risk
of birth defects
or it might be the other way around
maybe women with a history of birth
defects take more vitamins and these
women are at a higher risk of having a
baby with birth defects if that were the
case then our analysis good
underestimate the beneficial effect of
folic acid on birth defects folic acid
might reduce the risk by say 50% but
because the high risk women are more
likely to take folic acid we only see a
35% lower risk
like any observational study this one
may be affected by compounding which
means that in our analysis we will need
to adjust for variables like education
and prior history or birth defects and
in particular it turns out that there is
a variable L in our dataset and if we
adjust for L the estimate moves from a
35% reduction to only a 20% reduction in
risk that's a big change so do we need
to adjust for L then what is the closest
to the true effect of folic acid the
unadjusted estimate of 35 percent lower
risk or the L adjusted estimate of 20
percent lower risk questions like this
arise constantly in research studies and
by the end of this lesson you will know
how to handle these questions you will
be able to explain under which
circumstances you would want to adjust
for a very well L to quantify the effect
of folic acid on the risk of neuron to
defense